[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen und was im Sport
passiert ist das erfahren Sie von Sven
Voß zum Beispiel vom tennis- und vom
Fußball und unter anderem auf diese
Themen schauen wir auch
große Probleme an den Grundschulen immer
mehr Viertklässler in Deutschland lesen
schlecht
mittlerweile hat jeder vierte
gravierende Probleme
Geständnis aus der Chefetage
ex-audi-vorstand Stadler räumt und
dieses Skandal Fehler ein und dann geht
sowohl eine Gefängnisstrafe
und der Clan der die Juwelen raubte
dreieinhalb Jahre nach dem Einbruch im
Grünen Gewölbe in Dresden werden fünf
junge Männer verurteilt
die Ergebnisse sind erschreckend immer
mehr Kinder in Deutschland können gegen
Ende der Grundschulzeit nicht richtig
lesen das zeigt eine internationale
Untersuchung die abgekürzt Iglo heißt
wie dramatisch die Lage ist zeigen diese
Zahlen 2001 konnten 17 Prozent der
Viertklässler nicht ausreichend lesen
2016 waren es 18,9 Prozent
2021 dann ein drastischer Anstieg auf
25,4 Prozent also ein Viertel aller
Kinder hat schon nach der Grundschule
nur noch schlechte Chancen auf einen
guten Schulabschluss Christel Haas
berichtet die Rechnungen sind sehr
kompliziert
Lesetraining in der 4c der Goetheschule
in Mainz geübt wird nicht mit dem
Lesebuch sondern mit dem kinderteil der
Lokalzeitung
ich mag jetzt auch nicht so lesen wenn
da keine Bilder sind ich lese am
liebsten abends oder auch im Laden weil
die ist das klingt eigentlich
vielversprechend die Wirklichkeit aber
ist bei vielen Kindern eine andere
nämlich eine niederschmetternde
Viertklässler in Deutschland lesen
deutlich schlechter als noch vor 20
Jahren ein Viertel kann nicht richtig
lesen so steht es schwarz auf weiß in
der neuen lesekompetenzstudie die
wichtigsten Ursachen Schulschließungen
und Fernunterricht während der Pandemie
zu wenig Zeit fürs Lesen im Unterricht
und nach wie vor entscheidet die soziale
Herkunft über Erfolg oder Misserfolg in
der Schule genau in diesem Punkt stellt
die Studie der deutschen Bildungspolitik
ein Armutszeugnis aus 20 Jahren hat sich
damit im Hinblick auf die
Bildungsgerechtigkeit und
Chancengleichheit in Deutschland
praktisch nichts verändert deutsche
Schüler im Dauer lese tief und die
Erkenntnis dass auch die Politik seit
Jahren zu wenig für die Jüngsten tut
diese Ergebnisse sind alarmierend ein
weiter so darf es unter keinen Umständen
geben wir brauchen dringend eine
bildungspolitische Trendwende wie aber
soll die aussehen die Verfasser der
Studie empfehlen Kinder gezielt zu
fördern auch schon im Vorschulalter und
auch Eltern können selbst viel tun
wir können alle zu Hause etwas tun damit
eben Kinder besser lesen können wir
wissen dass Kinder denen regelmäßig
vorgelesen wird selbst besser lesen
lernen zum Schluss zumindest in der 4c
der Goetheschule spielt Lesen schon
jetzt eine große Rolle Deutschland hat
viel aufzuholen
es ist das erste Geständnis eines
ehemaligen vw-vorstandes in dieses
Skandal vor dem Landgericht München hat
Rupert Stadler der frühere Chef von Audi
zugegeben nicht eingegriffen zu haben
nachdem er von der betrugs-software
erfahren hatte im Gegenzug für sein
Geständnis muss Stadler wohl nicht ins
Gefängnis über den aufsehenerregenden
Prozess Claudia Vogelmann nach 167
Verhandlungstagen liefert er Rupert
Stadler der frühere Vorstandsvorsitzende
der AUDI AG angeklagt in der
dieselaffäre wegen Betrugs gesteht er
lässt sein Geständnis von seiner
Verteidigerin Vorlesen ein Geständnis
dass den Tatvorwurf der jetzt zuletzt
noch gegen ihn erhoben wird nämlich der
Tatvorwurf des Betrugs durch Unterlassen
dieser Tatvorwurf wird durch dieses
Geständnis abgedeckt seit Mai 2018 gilt
Rupert Stadler als Beschuldigter im
abgasskandal wegen Verdunklungsgefahr
kam er für vier Monate in U-Haft der
dieselskandal beschäftigt die Justiz
seit vielen Jahren war diversen Motoren
konnten die abgasnorme nicht eingehalten
werden bei Audi setzte man auf illegale
abschaltereinrichtungen die den hohen
Schadstoffausstoß vertuschen sollten vor
wenigen Wochen hatte das Landgericht
München signalisiert da Stadler mit
einer bewährungs- und Geldstrafe davon
kommen könnte wenn er gesteht so ein
Deal im Strafprozess ist sehr viel
besser als es beim ersten Hinhören so
klingt wenn von ihm profitieren alle
Seiten der Angeklagte natürlich durch
den milderes Urteil aber auch der Staat
weil er Zeit und Geld spart und auch
weil er Erkenntnisse bekommt durch das
Geständnis die er oft auch in
langwierigen Prozessen nicht erhalten
würde
Rupert Stadler der frühere
Vorstandsvorsitzende der AUDI AG wird
das Gericht in die juni voraussichtlich
als verurteilter Straftäter verlassen
jedoch als freier Mann
und wir blicken in die Ukraine dort gab
es einen Angriff auf Kiel nach Angaben
der ukrainischen Armee sein alle Raketen
abgeschossen worden darunter auch
russische Hyperschall Raketen vom Typ
kindscheide so der ukrainische
Verteidigungsminister resnikow die
kindscheibe von Russland als wunderbarer
bezeichnet die man eigentlich nicht
abfangen könne harte Kämpfe gibt es um
bachmut Tim Krüger war hinter der Front
bei einer sanitätseinheit
es ist ein ruhiger morgen für die
ukrainische Einheit am evakuierungs- und
erste-hilfepunkt nur wenige Kilometer
hinter der Front von bachmuth die
Sanitäter und Ärzte versorgen hier
verwundete Soldaten damit sie für den
Transport zur Weiterbehandlung stabil
sind
immer auf Standby weil in der 1 Minute
eine Person in der anderen minute aber
10 Personen gebracht werden können
am Mittag dann ist das passiert was sie
hier schon so viele Male erleben mussten
ein gepanzertes Fahrzeug bringt einen
Soldaten der an der Front durch
Schrapnelle verletzt wurde
er hat einen offenen Bruch am Bein und
sein Unterarm ist verletzt wir haben ihn
versorgt und Infusion gegeben
24 Stunden dauert eine Schicht immer
wieder ist entfernt der gefechtslam zu
hören aber immerhin rund 95% der
Verwundeten könnten sie retten sagen sie
der 28-Jährige ihor ist seit einem
halben Jahr im Einsatz jeder Handgriff
muss jetzt sitzen Emotionen kann er sich
nicht leisten ich mache nur meinen Job
und ich weiß dass ich zu tun habe jeder
muss seine Aufgabe in diesem Krieg
erfüllen
das ist auch für die medizinischen
Helfer und Helferinnen gefährlich denn
die evakuierungspunkte selbst können
Ziel von Angriffen werden
ich träume wie jeder in der Armee davon
zu meiner Familie zurückzukehren gesund
und leben und so tun Sie alles damit so
viele Soldaten und Soldaten in wie
möglich den Krieg überstehen gesund und
lebend
wie kann Russland für den Krieg und all
die Schäden in der Ukraine haftbar
gemacht werden das ist ab heute das
Thema auf dem Gipfel des Europarates
Scholz macron Meloni dutzende
regierungschefinnen und Chefs sind dafür
nach Island gereist zum ersten Treffen
seit 20 Jahren
der Europarat schon vor über 70 Jahren
gegründet ist eine der ältesten
politischen Organisationen in Europa
neben den 27 Staaten die inzwischen in
der EU sind zählen noch 19 weitere dazu
wie Großbritannien die Ukraine und die
Türkei zum Europarat gehört auch der
Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte Russland ist nach dem
Angriff auf die Ukraine nicht mehr dabei
im Europarat und da vor Ort verfolgt das
Gipfeltreffen Isabel Schäfers für uns
Isabel es geht also darum Russland für
die Schäden in der Ukraine
ja hier hinter mir kommen gerade die
Staats- und Regierungschefs an und hier
ist vor allem eine Botschaft zu hören
nämlich Unterstützung vom Europarat für
das Mitgliedsland Ukraine und ganz
konkret soll hier der Startschuss fallen
für ein internationales schadensregister
für die Ukraine die Vereinten Nationen
hatten bereits empfohlen dass die
Schäden die durch Russland verursacht
wurden dokumentiert werden sollen und
der Europarat der nimmt das jetzt in die
Hand so ein schadensregister das könnte
dann künftig bei Gerichtsverfahren gegen
Russland herangezogen werden und auch
für die Berechnung von
Reparationszahlungen an die Ukraine
Präsident selenski und Bundeskanzler
Scholz hatten das Ganze am Wochenende
auch noch mal unterstützt als sie sich
in Berlin getroffen haben und werden das
hier heute wohl auch noch mal
wiederholen das Ganze hätte auch einen
positiven Nebeneffekt für die
Institution Europarat denn die steckt ja
in einer Identitätskrise seit sie
Russland ausgeschlossen hat letztes Jahr
und mit einem solchen schadensregister
hätten Sie jetzt ganz aktuell eine neue
Aufgabe die auch noch den Kern des
Europarats treffen würde nämlich das
Überwachen von Menschenrechten und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit in Europa danke für
diese Einschätzung Isabel Schäfers
und in der Ukraine wurde heute der
Präsident des Obersten Gerichtshofes
wegen des Verdachts auf Korruption
festgenommen der Vorwurf er soll
Bestechungsgeldern Höhe von 2,5
Millionen Euro entgegengenommen haben
auch bei anderen Richtern gibt es
Razzien Korruption ist in der Ukraine
weit verbreitet die Eindämmung der
Korruption ist Voraussetzung für eine
EU-Mitgliedschaft des Landes
die Zahl der gerichtlich angeordneten
Hinrichtungen weltweit ist im letzten
Jahr weiter angestiegen besonders
drastisch im Nahen Osten und Nordafrika
meldet amnest international insgesamt
seien 2022 offiziell 883 Todesstrafen
vollstreckt worden mit Abstand die
meisten davon in den Ländern Iran
Saudi-Arabien und Ägypten dazu kämen
noch tausende geheim gehalten
Hinrichtungen mutlassig vor allem in
China Nordkorea und Vietnam
AR ist die Zahl der Toten durch Zyklon
Mocca offenbar deutlich höher als
bislang befürchtet laut der
oppositionellen nationalen
Einheitsregierung kam mindestens 400
Menschen ums Leben bei den meisten Toten
soll es sich um Angehörige der
muslimischen Minderheit der rohinsche
Handeln viele von ihnen leben in
notdürftigen Unterkünften rund um die
Stadt Citroën oder Sturm besonders
heftig wütete
viele Krankenhäuser in Deutschland
stehen am Rand des finanziellen Ruins
auch deshalb plant
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
eine krankenhausreform Pläne die er
heute auf dem Ärztetag in Essen wieder
als dringend benötigt verteidigte im
Kern soll es Häuser für die
Grundversorgung geben und spezialisierte
Kliniken Nordrhein-Westfalen hat ein
ähnlichen Ansatz Peter Böhmer
die Kliniken Essen Mitte haben eine der
größten gynäkologischen Onkologie in
Deutschlands Brustkrebsbehandlung etwa
in der Onkologie wollen sie sich noch
stärker spezialisieren die Wiese nicht
mehr viele Fachrichtungen anbieten
sondern in wenigen richtig gut sein
Spezialisierung bedeutet dass sich die
Ressourcen Bündel in einem bestimmten
fällt das heißt dass ich dort besonders
gut sein kann und auch besonders gute
Pflege besonders gute Medizin anbieten
kann damit liegen sie auf Linie der
neuen Krankenhausplanung in NRW
Krankenhäuser sollen sich spezialisieren
so sollen Doppelstrukturen und ruinöser
Wettbewerb etwa in einer Großstadt
vermieden werden ein landesgutachten
sagt es gibt Überversorgung in
Ballungszentren und Unterversorgung auf
dem Land zudem zu wenig Orientierung am
tatsächlichen Bedarf und der
Behandlungsqualität
damit soll Schluss sein künftig sollen
Politik Kassen und Krankenhäuser vor Ort
festlegen was ein Krankenhaus für die
Bedürfnisse anbieten muss deswegen
wollen wir gerne festlegen welches
Krankenhaus in welcher Region macht zum
Beispiel in erster Linie die
Herzinfarkte wer macht die Schlaganfälle
dass wir dann eine Strukturqualität
vorgeht Patienten Schütze haben
allerdings Zweifel ob Reformen wie in
NRW auch die Versorgung auf dem Land
verbessern werden was wir brauchen ist
die Versorgung der Kranken
Menschen und hier sehen wir dass die
Krankenhäuser immer mehr schließen
heruntergefahren werden das macht
Patientinnen und Patienten Angst unklar
auch wie viele Krankenhäuser am Ende
übrig bleiben denn klar ist es muss und
soll gespart werden
Polizei Gewalt in Deutschland da gibt es
bei der Erfassung und Verfolgung
offenbar Lücken zudem Ergebnis kommen
forschende der Universitäten Frankfurt
und Bochum in einer Studie befragt
wurden mehr als 3.300 Betroffene aber
auch Vertreterinnen und Vertreter von
Polizei Justiz und Beratungsstellen
laut Studie kommt es nur äußerst selten
nämlich in zwei Prozent der Fälle
überhaupt zur Anklage und falls Anklage
erhoben wird würden die Verfahren im
mehr als 90% der Fälle eingestellt
ZDF heute live diskutiert mit einem
Kriminologen und einem Polizisten die
Ergebnisse der Studie um 19:30 Uhr in
der App und auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen
mit einer Axt gingen sie auf den
Schaukasten los clauten historische
Juwelen aus Sachsens schatzkammermuseum
der Einbruch in das Grüne Gewölbe in
Dresden bei einer der spektakulärsten
Kunstdiebstahl in Deutschland
dreieinhalb Jahre danach hat das
Landgericht Dresden fünf Täter zur
Haftstrafen verurteilt ein Urteil dem
ein Deal vorausging Steffi Moritz mit
Einzelheiten
mit Haftstrafen zwischen vier und sechs
Jahren dürften die fünf Angeklagten
allesamt Mitglieder des
arabischstämmigen remo-plans sehr
zufrieden sein ein sechster
Beschuldigter wurde freigesprochen aus
Mangel an Beweisen es waren November
2019 als sie im weltberühmten Grünen
Gewölbe in Dresden Schmuckstücke mit
über 4.000 Diamanten erbeuteten jehoher
Wert liegt in ihrer Einzigartigkeit das
hatten die Liebe bei der Vermarktung
nicht bedacht denn verkaufen ließen sich
die Schätze deshalb wohl nicht es kam zu
einem ganz speziellen Deal zwischen
Staatsanwaltschaft und Verteidiger
Juwelen und Geständnisse gegen wenige
Haftjahre ohne Deal hätte es zumindest
auf absehbare Zeit keine Rückgabe des
Schmuckes gegeben und es ist auch
deutlich geworden die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden haben keinen
Ansatz gehabt wo Schmuck sich befinden
könnte
insgesamt waren die Beweise erdrückend
und die angedrohten Haftstrafen hoch
sodass die Angeklagten Ende letzten
Jahres über ihre Anwälte einen Großteil
des Schmucks zurückgaben allerdings
stark beschädigt die Gegenleistung heute
ein mildes Strafmaß drei Beschuldigte
kommen erstmal auf freien Fuß bis das
Urteil rechtsgültig ist werden dann ihre
Haftstrafe in Wohnortnähe verbüßen
können zwei Angeklagte müssen allerdings
aufgrund einer früheren Verurteilung im
Gefängnis bleiben sie waren am Diebstahl
der Goldmünze am Berliner bodenmuseum
beteiligt
das Gesicht der DDR Nachrichtensendung
aktuelle Kamera Klaus Feldmann ist tot
er starb im Alter von 87 Jahren zu Hause
in Berlin Feldmann war über viele
Jahrzehnte bis 1989 Sprecher der Sendung
und wurde 14 mal zum DDR fernsehliebling
gewählt nach der Wende ginge offen mit
seiner Tätigkeit für das staatliche
DDR-Fernsehen um und veröffentlichte
mehrere Bücher unter anderem zur Arbeit
als Journalist im Sozialismus
in Deutschland und in ganz Europa sind
viele Vogelarten seltener geworden die
Bestände nahmen seit 1980 und rund ein
Viertel ab eine großangelegte
europäische Studie hat jetzt die Gründe
dafür ermittelt Hauptursache für den
Rückgang ist demnach die intensive
Landwirtschaft
Pestizide reduzieren die Anzahl der
Insekten die vielen Vögeln als Futter
dienen weitere Gründe sind die
Verstädterung und die Klimakrise obwohl
in vielen Ländern die Bewaldung zunimmt
wurden insgesamt auch dort die Vögel
weniger
der rote Teppich entkern ist ausgerollt
voilà das Filmfest hat eben begonnen
natürlich mit Stars aus aller Welt und
erstmals mit einer Frau an der Spitze
und die kommt aus Deutschland ihres
Knoblauch und auch deutsche Filme haben
es in den Wettbewerb geschafft über die
76 Festspielen kann die Filme und den
glamo berichtet Thomas Walde
das große schaulaufenden kann hat
begonnen und der rote Teppich hat seine
eigenen Regeln je bekannter die
Gesichter desto später die Ankunft Paula
Bär und Franz Rogowski gefolgt von
Katrin de nerve von Uma Thurman Mats
mikelsen er lässt noch ein paar Tage auf
sich warten Harrison Ford kommt nach
kann mit einer neuen Ausgabe aus der
Indiana Jones Reihe
auch sonst immer den alten Hollywood
Recken Johnny Depp spielte dem
Eröffnungsfilm Ludwig den 15 die Jury
des Festivals äußerte sich derweil zum
Wettbewerb um die Goldene Palme
manchmal ist eine Stimme in einer Jury
besonders entschieden und alle anderen
folgen dann hinterher ich will so eine
Konsensbildung verhindern jedes Jury
Mitglied soll sich erst einmal frei
aussprechen können
das bringt zwei Filme mit nach kann
einer zeigt Leben und Werk des Künstlers
an seinem Kiefer
Menschen suchen
nicht sehen wollen den Abgrund nicht den
von Grund auf wollen die Leute das nicht
sehen um gibt's diese Leichtigkeit
leichte und schwere Kost gibt es auf dem
Filmmarkt hier kauft und verkauft die
Branche all die Werke die von kann aus
ein Weltpublikum finden sollen
leicht was auch beim Tennis nicht sven
hat sie die deutsche Nummer eins aber
trotzdem nicht vom Regen aufhalten
lassen ja das Wetterchaos in Rom hatte
Alexander esvereves Matchplan schon
ordentlich durcheinandergewirbelt
gestern musste das Spiel gegen den
US-Amerikaner Jeffrey Wolf abgebrochen
werden bei der Fortsetzung heute zog der
deutsche Olympiasieger aber souverän ins
Achtelfinale ein die Frühschicht ist rum
Zwettl erledigt die erste Aufgabe des
Tages um die Mittagszeit der
Olympiasieger braucht keine halbe Stunde
um das Match zu Ende zu bringen das
gestern bei 3:3 im zweiten Satz
unterbrochen wurde er hat mehr gute
Schläge macht weniger Fehler gegen
Jeffrey John Wolf aus den USA und am
Netz klappt es auch
als wäre der gewinnt mit sechs zu vier
und sieben zu fünf und spielt noch am
Abend gegen den Russen Daniel Medvedev
gegen den er kürzlichen Monte Carlo
verlor und den er danach als unfairsten
Spieler der Welt bezeichnet hatte
zu einer Aussprache in Rom trifft man
sich wieder
[Applaus]
am 17 Juni werden in Berlin die Special
Olympics World Games eröffnet die
Wettkämpfe der Menschen mit geistiger
Einschränkung werden großflächig live
übertragen auch das ZDF zeigt die
besonderen Spiele in der Hauptstadt die
Stadt hat gezeigt dass sie weltoffen ist
dass sie offen ist für Diversität und
dass sie auch offen ist für Integration
und die Special Olympics sind einfach
das Beste was der Sport zeigen kann
Integration pur und mit mehr als 7000
Athletinnen und Athleten und der Spaß
der wird ganz sicherlich auch nicht zu
kurz kommen ich freue mich drauf
wirklich wir auch der FC Liverpool hat
das Ticket für Europa sicher das 13:0
gegen lässt das City war der 7 Sieg in
Folge für den Tabellen fünften damit
spielt das Team von Jürgen Klopp in der
kommenden Saison mindestens in der
Europa liegt hält die Siegesserie an
könnte es sogar noch für die Champions
League
[Applaus]
das war's vom Sport Jana danke schön
morgen wird's noch mal etwas kühler zum
Wochenende steigen die Temperaturen
wieder an mehr zum Wetter gleich mit
Christa Orben Dunja liebe Grüße um 21:45
Uhr zum heute journal machen sie es gut
[Musik]
ja guten Abend gelb blüht zur Zeit der
Raps jetzt wird es mit Luft aus dem
Nordwesten aber noch mal spürbar Kühler
zwar breitet sich dazu meist hoher
Luftdruck zu uns aus aber dieses
unwettertief übermittelt Italien das
beeinflusst doch unseren Süden und zwar
mit Dauerregen an den Alpen und im
südlichen Alpenvorland bis morgen Mittag
können um 50 Liter pro Quadratmeter in
24 Stunden zusammenkommen und dazu singt
die Schneefallgrenze auf 1000 m
ansonsten ist es weg sind bewölkt heute
Nacht je nach Bewölkung sinken die
Temperaturen auf 7 bis 0 Grad in den
Mittelgebirgen ist vereinzelt Bodenfrost
möglich in der Nacht auf Donnerstag dann
ist aber ganz verbreitet in Deutschland
Bodenfrost drin und dann schützen Sie am
besten ihre Frost empfindlichen Pflanzen
morgen ist es auch tagsüber ein eher
kühler mai Tag mit 11 Grad an den Küsten
17 Grad im Rhein-Main-Gebiet und rund um
Berlin an den Alpen ist es noch mal
etwas kühler hier gibt es eben auch die
dichten Wolken der Dauerregen lässt im
Tagesverlauf aber nach ansonsten
wechseln sich Sonne und Wolken ab ein
bisschen ungemütlicher ist es an der
Nordseeküste mit etwas mehr Wolken und
einem böigen Nordwind der Feiertag der
läuft dann aber meist trocken ab und bis
zum Wochenende wird es deutlich milder
am Samstag schon bis 24 Grad tschüss